As you gain experience with game
development, you may find yourself
creating your own specialized tools,
maybe more than you'd expect.
Sometimes there's just no better way to
convert a data file into the format you
need or extract font data
to create a custom texture.
One tool you commonly have
to write as a level editor
which can sometimes grow into
a full blown project of its own.
If your game levels are big and
complex, a custom level editor can
end up saving time in the long run.
And it makes it much easier to release
new content to keep your game fresh.
It also allows others
to build levels for
your game which can be a great
way to engage your audience.
It's still a good idea to represent your
levels with human readable data files.
Because they tend to be
platform independent.
And you also preserve the flexibility to
make changes with a simple text editor.
You might choose to use binary data
files in production null to save space.
And it's easy to add
a binary export function.
If you write a dedicated level editor.
I always enjoyed writing tools and
thought it was interesting how
tool development kind of happens in
reverse compared to the game itself.
Tools are usually needed right away, so
there's a flurry of
coding activity up front.
Games, on the other hand,
tend to gel at the end,
it's all the individual
components come together.
So, if you're creating a game,
and the tools used to build it.
Well, you're going to be very
busy right from the start.